The last thing I'm going to
talk about is custom operators.
Custom operators allow us to define
completely new operators that we can use
in our code.
To create a new operator,
you need to specify what kind
of operator it is first.
Is it a prefix operator, an infix
operator, or a postfix operator?
So you specify the type of operator,
operator, and
then the symbol you want to use for
the operator.
So, we'll use the bank
symbol in this case.
So now that we know what the symbol is
for this operator, we need to define
a function that tells the compiler
what kind of operand it accepts, and
what it returns.
The reason I'm using the word
operand instead of parameter is,
that's just conventional when
we're talking about operators.
The arguments that they accept
are referred to as operands.
This one keeps things simple, and
it takes a string operand, and
it returns a string.
Then what the operator actually does,
is add the dis prefix to
whatever the word operand was.
And now we can use this
operator right in our code,
and we can see that we get disassociate,
and disconnect, and disappear.
Now let's look at an infix operator.
For an infix operator we need to define
its associativity and precedence, and so
it's a little bit different
than the prefix operator.
Here we've assigned this to left
associative and it's precedence to 155.
And then the rest of the operator
definition continues like we saw.
For this operator, we're going to take
two operands, which are integers, and
then return another Int.
I'm going to give you a second to see if
you can figure out what this operator is
actually doing.
So go ahead, take a second and
see if you can figure it out.
If you guessed exponentiation, or
the exponent, then you got it right.
So, for this first example we have here,
we're raising 5 to the second power and
this gives us a result of 25.
And then we take and chain it together,
so this is actually computing 25.
I could just write 25.
And then it's raising that to
the second power and giving us 625.
Now I'll skip on down to the bottom for
our postfix example.
This definition's similar to the prefix
example and it takes one operand and
returns a result.
In this case, we're taking an Int and
we're returning a Double.
So you'll notice that it doesn't have
to be the case that the types of
the operands match the return type.
And this operator's pretty slick.
It converts an integer
followed by a percent sign
into its decimal representation.
Now that's pretty cool.